[Music]
all right well thank you so much for
coming out especially after we drank all
the beer last night today I'll be
talking about how JavaScript devs can
change the way that we build tools and
how they already are and this is
probably not news to any of y'all so my
name is Amelia Abreu and like it charlie
graciously introduced me I live in
Portland Oregon I'm a design researcher
and I've always been obsessed with
categories I'm cuban-american that from
Texas who lived in the northwest for
most of my adult life so it's hard
sometimes to answer the question where
are you from
and I'd like to start out with the point
that categories and distinctions matter
and this is probably not news to JSS
after all and language without classes
it requires the imposed classifications
yes so today I'm going to talk about
what distinction and classification why
these little things matter share some of
my notes and observations from working
on development and security tools over
the past few years and make an argument
that there's a lot at stake here and
that we can do better and we need to do
better from a usability standpoint I
always say that usability like security
is best baked in early on
and as we as a full-stack j/s reaches
more and more momentum it's more
important to think about this so Who am
I and why am I talking to you about this
I'm a design researcher and I'll speak a
little bit about how hate the word user
I would never describe anyone are
respected as a user but the term user
experience seems to be stuck to this
area and over the past few years I've
worked I've been working more on
security and engineering tools and as a
result I've interviewed a lot of
developers and worked with a lot more
and I often find that my relationship to
the deaf community is somehow is a
little bit anthropological and prior to
this I worked on a PhD in human-computer
interaction u-dub and Seattle and I
before that I was a librarian and my
first career was as a music writer and
when I look back on these various
threads the thing that this hasn't these
all have in common is that involved they
all involve listening to people talk
about complex and technical subjects and
this you know ongoing interaction with
classification and systems I also want
to note that something that has shaped
my felt zhang has been that i'm a child
of the 1980s texas hardware boom my
grandfather worked for Texas Instruments
my mother was a mainframe operator and
neither one of these were very glamorous
jobs but definitely shaped my
understanding of how you know the
pecking order of hardware and software
and obviously we're living in a much
different around these days so first
we're going to talk about distinction
and so as Pierre Bourdieu said taste
classifies and a class
classifier so in the 1970s French
sociologist Pierre Bourdieu surveyed
thousands of folks and found that their
interests their preferences reflected
not only their economic status in life
but also their cultural status so if you
like Pachulia Clark that puts you at a
very middlebrow status but if you like
shopping at the flea market and you know
that puts you in this in this square of
artistic producers and cultural capital
and this is something that I think we we
can think about unless of a strict less
of a stratified way but in a way of
thinking okay the way that we work the
way that we are aesthetics they matter
and they say a lot about us Bourdieu
also map this to the foods that folks
like to eat and then gastronomic a
magazine and 2015 updated this so where
your homemade pickles come from says a
lot about you so in the past few years
I've been working a lot on developer
tools and the term a developer
experience that has come about and I
like it okay because the word user are
as Brenda Laurel says that demeaning
little word user is not something you
would use to describe someone who you
respected I would call you know a
friend's bad boyfriend
oh he's a user so how do we you know how
do we bring more of that sense that
we're working with folks to build tools
that they can use tools that they'll
integrate into their everyday lives and
everyday work and that as developers
will be using using whatever's at our
hand RM
at our disposal to build better things
for the end-user or for you know for
someone else down the line and there's
not really a good nomenclature for that
if anyone has any suggestions feel free
to bring them to me after after the
presentation yeah so how do you how does
one do this and I find that this is
something that is often mysterious I
work a lot with ethnographic interviews
which means I will bring the team that
I'm working with into the field to go
hang out with the people who will use
the products that they're building and I
always say that I'm going to write a
book about doing user research that's it
that's a scanned em questions over and
over I'll often ask people what seemed
like very obvious questions and then
listen and if that takes a lot of
humility and also patience but so when
we do comment too we do come to users
with little expectation a little
assumption that's where we can learn the
most about work patterns about needs
about workarounds yesterday's
presentation and blows my my mind is
blanking because I'm jet lagged but
there was a really great there's there's
a really great explanation about
workarounds in a presentation yesterday
that I loved and for DES it's often hard
to distinguish between what about the
users of your product are going to be
different than you and your team and I
always like to start with this question
well what text editor do you use because
if you're using Emacs you will have very
you will have different keyboard
shortcuts and different different usage
patterns and say someone using them
and this is a this is often an issue
when it comes to developer tools because
they're they often come out of a roll
your own solution
I automate something in my job I share
it with my boss I share it with my team
we say oh let's let's bring this to it
to the greater public and the this is
this onion you see here this comes from
a framework called cognitive work
analysis which was developed in the 50s
to understand how pilots and nuclear
opera nuclear power plant operators
related to their dashboards and
negotiated their work and I offer
I also I like to call this the Homer
Simpson donut because at the end of the
day we are all Homer Simpson trying to
make sense of something that's often
complex and not really designed for us
and you can see here this is using the
type on dove to better understand how
they use to the tools so I often work
with I would work with a fairly
conventional hardware company as a
software company and the idea of full
stack chaos makes them very nervous it's
like in nature and as folks as the node
foundation like to say 500 of Fortune
five all 500 of Fortune 500 companies
are running node however this does just
does it disrupt some very long held
beliefs about web devs in this very
hardware centric hierarchy of things and
oftentimes when I go into the field and
interview JSDF the way that they work is
different than say some what folks
working quote unquote closer to the
metal
and I'll tell you a little bit about the
differences that I've found and this is
based on qualitative research I do not
have a large scale demographic sent to
to support this but this is something
that I would urge you all to think about
is thinking about where can we get you
know collecting more demographics about
about the backgrounds of your fellow Jo
stoves and quantifying how this is a
more diverse and less conventional
community then we might remind our
previously ascribed to to software or
server-side development and that's the
first that's the first insight and it's
probably not news to anyone here is that
because there is no one standard way to
become a JavaScript developer oftentimes
JSF will acknowledge this plurality and
oftentimes they'll interview folks who
work in teams together and they'll say
yeah like I do things totally different
than him and this is something that I
find that J is devs are far more
comfortable with than some of their
counterparts and this is a strength I
would argue that this is something that
we want to acknowledge and see as a
strength I think it makes for better
products some more diverse user base and
I've also found and this is something
that seems a little a little bit
wishy-washy but I want you to bear with
me I found that since many J as doves
came of age during the during desktop
centric frameworks but have since moved
into mobile and Internet of Things
projects so they have a better
conception of of code living in the wild
and living in the physical realm and I
also find that a lot of the jobs that I
interview have interests in the physical
realm whether they're knitter
or skateboarders or mountain bikers and
this is something that is seen not as an
emic to making software but something is
seen as as something that complements it
and this is once again through pushing
back on the more immaterial
sensibilities of the traditional you
know neckbeard security developers that
I work with this that term is used with
respect and the last and maybe most
quantifiable and most important finding
that I've made in over the past few
years is that jeaious devs
oftentimes coming from from front-end
work have had a better idea of of
advocating for the end user and they
often speak with a desire to help others
I was working on an Internet of Things
security tool this past year and one of
the doves said to me you know I don't
want to make an insecure baby
surveillance device and this was very
self-aware I thought this was and also
very aware of the impact that that this
that ones work had in the world but
we're at a crossroads here having a
desire to help others is not the same as
actually helping others and I find that
you know notions of advocacy are all
well and good but they're often there's
often a conflict about how to actually
put those into action I often say that
doing what I do I often I often come to
the table when things are already on
fire and how do we in my goal in
the work that I do is helping you all to
smell the smoke because here's the thing
I am very sick of empathy as a corporate
buzzword empathy to me is Bill Clinton
saying I feel your pain it's a
gratifying thing to dispense of and it's
often and it's often you know rewarding
to to to hear it if someone emphasizes
with you but empathy without action is
pretty meaningless so how do we build
advocacy if you have if you haven't run
across this the scene from the
indigenous of the group indigenous
action I would really encourage it and I
find that we want we need to think about
our user our end users and the folks we
work with as accomplices not allies we
want to be with them while they while
they use the products that we build and
that we need end that in order to do
that we need to build trust and consent
no one is going to let us end no one is
going to trust us until we build that
trust and we build that trust by walking
alongside them by acknowledging those
diverse viewpoints and building meaning
into our data gathering oftentimes when
I work on developer products there's not
a really good explanation of who it's
actually for and this is something that
I find that Jas devs have a very low
[ __ ] meter for you know what's the
story behind this why am I supposed to
use it why doesn't this this doesn't
make sense with what I'm doing
often I work on an API
this past year that was developed by by
folks working in sea and the way that
the the class the way that the the calls
were formed just didn't match jeaious
syntax at all at all I mean not that
there's any rhyme or reason to jeaious
and syntax but that's not my own field
of expertise yeah and this is something
that I find with developer tools that we
need to give a reason for folks to use
it
we need to explicate the stories and cut
and make a case for it because unless
and there are some notable exceptions to
this but unless we make a case for use
it for usable security solution or for
an easily implementable security
solution it's not going to happen
and I think that in this community our
diversity is our strength but we need
ways to understand our impact and I'll
repeat my plea to build you know bill it
build more data on you know demographic
diversity build more data on who on
who's deploying jas frameworks at every
level of the stack and how it's
different how workflows are different
and how and how this this makes for a
better impact and I think that the that
this is especially important when our
work impacts very vulnerable people I'm
often in the in the the jargon around
the internet of things Aging in Place is
a big buzzword and if we're going to be
building tools for grandmas for folks
who are living in with limited mobility
and living
and you know limited economic capacity
we need to be more aware of how our how
our work impacts them likewise as we
didn't want to follow the we-vibe
class-action lawsuit as we put as we put
connected technologies into realms that
we would consider to be very private we
need to make sure that we are protecting
our users as data and you know notions
about notions of empathy and notions of
advocacy are all well and good but until
the rubber hits the road when we are
when we're in this when we're in this
very intimate and necessary and
necessarily trustworthy place and this
is the argument I always make to my
clients it's that not to is that we
shouldn't discount even though it's
generalist or tinkerer devs because if
they cannot grok your security tool then
we're not going to have security and we
need to invest in design and
documentation that does accommodate a
larger span of of users even when those
users are not traditional not what we
consider to be traditional devs
or traditional implementers of security
this is a big task and I think it's
something that will require rebuilding
trust not only amongst folks new coming
in but also amongst the long range users
of our products and at every level of
the software device and hardware
development so what do we do next where
do we go from here I you know will proud
this will probably be no surprise to you
but I advocate for understanding
developer experiences
at every step of the process if you are
working on a roll your own tool put it
in front of other people and do this
early and often IBM did these studies in
the early 90s that said that there was a
20 to 1 ROI on on early investments in
usability and that that ROI number was
increased the earlier we earlier on a
process usability testing is huge and
bringing your users in making a more
participatory stance when developing
your tools and their documentation and I
think that organizations the whole can
invest in understanding about these
differences in values and skill sets
because ultimately I hope that we can
work from this from a standpoint of the
ethics of care this is a big project
that I've been working on conjointly but
how do we see our work as caring for our
users not just giving them something
cool to use and I think that this is
something that we can bring to our work
and that reminds us of how important
what we're doing actually is and lastly
let's work together I recently started a
program called UX night school bringing
bringing design research tools to to
developers and designers in the field
and I'd love to work with you so thanks